you may know mike posner from his 2010
hit cooler than me and after five years
out of the spotlight his new song is
rocketing up the Billboard Hot 100 chart
and given him a second chance well I
think is hilarious
is it hilariously ironic because right I
wrote write this song I'm a I'm just a
singer who already blew a shot and then
the writing of that lyric and that song
that it was a part of has in essence
given me another shot like I'm in this
chair right now a year ago was not in
this chair hoser was at the top of his
game at 22 with his debut album but a
sophomore follow-up never happened
I was parading around the world making
very more money than I deserve it's
within my subsequent singles all failed
to replicate that success he struggled
with being in and out of the spotlight
even living in a van for a few months to
get away from the la lifestyle he
focused on writing and became the guy
behind hits like Justin Bieber's
boyfriend and maroon fives sugar
now the remix of this new song has more
than 120 million streams and county
and Mike isn't taking this rebirth for
granted a lesson learned at the height
of his career nearly six years ago my
focus is just trying to appreciate the
present moment more and more and more
you